hi I'm Erik Bosse and Deadpool to
somehow followed up Avengers infinity
war with big thrills and laughs while
completely changing the palette to
something that leaves the kiddies stuff
at home kind of like Logan but you know
what still uses Josh Brolin you can't
forget that special sauce specifically
the ending of Deadpool 2 and it's
post-credits scenes close out the movie
with a level of complexity and humor
that we almost never see in these kinds
of movies now I already broke down
Deadpool 2 for all the details and jokes
that you missed throughout the movie and
my other video but here let's take a
deeper look at the ending to clear up
any questions that you might have but
really to explore how it finishes off
Deadpool in such a satisfying oh I just
heard myself spoiler warning and let's
start with the first question
why did Deadpool sacrifice himself to
save Russel really just to some of
Deadpool's whole thought process here
from the moment Vanessa dies Wade has
become instantly aimless and suicidal
but because suicide isn't really an
option for Deadpool he spins this movie
desperate to find a purpose his repeated
brushes with death bring him close with
Vanessa in a spiritual realm she lead
more on that a second and ghost Vanessa
advises him to make sure his heart is in
the right place so he first interprets
this message as joining the x-men
believing his heart to belong with
Colossus and the rest of them but then
that leads him to protect Russell a
mutant victim he identifies with so he
turns on the x-men in order to protect
him and when Russell doesn't really want
that protection his last interpretation
of ghosts Vanessa's advice is a literal
one to literally put his heart in the
right place in front of cables bullet
while wearing the inhibitor collar to
make sure the shot is fatal
this self-sacrifice will show Russell
what true friendship looks like saving
Russell's soul and making it so that
cable won't need to assassinate the kid
so Deadpool ends up getting what he
wants his life to have meaning his heart
to be in the right place and his reunion
with Vanessa so are weighed in Vanessa
in heaven kinda depends who you pray to
the recurring imagery of Wade trying to
commune with Vanessa in this sunny
surreal version of their apartment I
think is meant to be interpreted sure it
could be heaven or some version of it
and Wade each time he comes close to
dying like blowing himself up or
drowning in the frozen lake goes here
and sees Vanessa's ghostly presence but
a barrier keeps him from crossing over
to it then
after taking the bullet Wade is able to
cross over transform him back into the
unscarred version of himself as it's
often the case in pop culture depictions
of heaven to be with his soulmate but
another way to look at this is this
could be a dream in Wade's imagination
since he can't die maybe his mind
created this imaginary vision of a place
that he goes to whenever he gets close
to this like I know to keep going down
this path we get a little metaphysical
is then you could argue that like every
afterlife could just be a vision in our
own heads but it is worth pointing out
that this relationship with ghost
Vanessa might be based on the Deadpool
comics one of Deadpool's lovers is
mistress death who's also Paris's love
interest in the comics by the way death
is the only figure who can elude that
pool since he is basically immortal this
kind of connection applies to Vanessa in
this movie she's also a spiritual
presence that he can never truly be with
but his brief reunion with her does not
last because cable decides to change
things last minute so why this cable
save Deadpool well one of the most
important elements in this movie is
Deadpool's relationship with cable which
is easy to overlook since it doesn't
really come up until the final third of
the movie cable for the most part
doesn't respect Deadpool he sees himself
as this noble hero launching himself
back in time to prevent a horrible
future and save his family meanwhile he
browsed a Deadpool you're no hero you're
a clown dressed up as a sex toy which he
has a perfect description of Deadpool
Deadpool jumping in front of the bullet
proves cable wrong
his daughters stuffed bear changes from
blood soaked to clean proving to cable
that Russell's heart truly has been
changed and Deadpool is even more of a
hero than he is Deadpool self-sacrifice
inspires cable to man up and make his
own self sacrifice because remember it's
not just the future of his family cables
worried about it's the future of their
whole civilization
he needs more heroes like Deadpool to be
alive in the present to keep the world
from going to hell that's why this song
choice of tomorrow from Annie is so
perfect in this moment cable is thinking
purely about what tomorrow the future
will look like
so cable realizes Deadpool needs to
survive but also he feels a personal
responsibility to facilitate that
process so instead of using his last
time travel charge to return to the
future he saves Deadpool and strands
himself in the present day of course
Cable does this by returning to right
before the final battle at the Essex
House and a funding
so if Yuri watched it cable returns to
precisely the moment that Deadpool
earlier said the words I wish I could
turn back time to take all that back
after awkwardly bringing up cables dead
daughter and then cable slips into
Deadpool suit the arcade token that he
stole from Deadpool earlier in the ice
box right into the spot where the bullet
will hit later Wade gave the nest of
this token right before she died as a
reminder of their first date which we
saw in the first movie sure it's a
little odd to make coins out of lead but
shut up it sweets this way both Vanessa
and cable play a part in saving Wade
Wilson's life it's nice the best part of
this is all of these events were
foreshadowed throughout the movie the
images of Deadpool's fatal wound in a
bullet hitting arcade tokens showed up
in that James Bond style opening title
sequence again check out my full movie
breakdown for more details on that but
lastly did the post-credits scenes
actually happen but kind of depends who
you pray to or our ability to separate
jokes from story so in the post credits
scenes we see negasonic teenage warhead
and ukyo riparian cables time travel
device and handing it over to deadpool
he then uses it to prevent Vanessa's
death and then to save Peter - because
it was the right thing to do following
this he kills the version of himself
from x-men origins and then Ryan
Reynolds's he reads the Green Lantern
script now it is possible that all of
these clips are really meant as meta
non-canon gags that are not part of the
story like we've entered a Bugs Bunny
universe where consequences no longer
exist and all of this is just what
Deadpool would do if he could for
America he would save his lady and Peter
and cover up the embarrassing career
moves he made but I am going to go with
the interpretation that Deadpool really
did save Vanessa in Peter just so we
don't get that confused if those two
show up in future movies it's just those
two scenes tonally seem to fit in more
with the rest of the movie
meanwhile Deadpool Medellin with x-men
origins and Green Lantern yeah those
just feel removed from everything else
they're clearly just jokes
I wouldn't think too hard about the
timelines here just laugh or don't but a
question for you guys do you think
cables screwed over Deadpool by bringing
him back to life
no rejoining your hot soulmate and a
heaven version of your apartment
cancer-free prettyboy looks restored
that's a pretty dope way to end up like
even if we take Wade saving Vanessa in a
post-credits scene as the actual events
in the story he's still kind of live in
pain constantly that butterface I know
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me directly at a vas or follow new
rockstars on Twitter for more updates on
our videos like and share this video
subscribe to new rockstars to see us go
into Deadpool over and over and I just
heard myself bye